was ist das denn das ist eine Lostrommel
und das ganze nennt sich fragen Lotto
das sind nette und gemeine Fragen die
roten also sind die gemeinen Fragen die
Grünen sind unglaublich nett lieb und
im brutalarmlos du kannst ziehen solange
Du willst zu viel du willst
einfach ziehen Vorlesen ich persönlich
wie du möchtest alle Möglichkeiten du
kannst auch schön genau
natürlich super du kannst sie auch
pikiert zur Seite werfen wenn sie dir
nicht in den Kram passt
boah sie lang sie müssen sich dumm und
dusselig verdient haben weil sie im
Fernsehen im Kino und auf der Bühne
hyperaktiv sind meinen Sie nicht dass
die Menschen sie langsam satt haben
schade Unverschämtheit habe ich mich
glaube ich noch nicht verdient und
ich achte darauf dass mich die Menschen
nicht satt bekommen von daher
glaube ich dass sie mich auch noch nicht
satt haben
aber hyperaktiv ist noch nicht ganz
daneben
hyperaktiv ich bin doch aber jetzt sitze
hier sehr gelassen
ich mache viel ja
aber also viel wieder ja auch mache ich
glaube ich noch nicht
irgendein 200 Stunden im Fernsehen
moderiert ja da bin ich noch weit von
entfernt
okay ich zieh weiter blind ja okay
jetzt mal grün zur Abwechslung
das ist ja wie auf dem auf der Kirmes wo
man Lose zieht mal sehen ob es ein
Gewinn ist
es immer ein Gewinn
vom switch-star zum Taxi Talker sie
können in der Gruppe aber auch als
Alleinunterhalter agieren wie schafft
man es sich so gut anzupassen und sich
dabei gleichzeitig perfekt in Szene zu
setzen
Menschenkenntnis
vielleicht also für das Taxi brauche ich
das ähm
Bodenständigkeit sich nicht über die
Leute erheben naja Gott ja es hat
einfach damit zu tun ich glaube man muss
flexibel bleiben man muss neugierig sein
und offen bleiben deswegen Twitter ich
auch deswegen mache ich irgendwie so
vieles Zeugs weil ich einfach so bin ich
einfach gestrickt also immer dasselbe zu
tun ist mir einfach zu langweilig und
deswegen mache ich so viele verschiedene
Sachen und versuche mich da auch die
Herausforderung einfach anzunehmen und
mich anzupassen
bist du dann Ausnahme
weiß ich nicht das müssen glaube ich
andere entscheiden aber ich halte mich
schon für wandelbar weil weil also
erstmal das Wandel Wandelbarkeit war für
mich immer der Inbegriff von
Schauspielerei also sich immer selber zu
spielen finde ich langweilig und gerade
als Parodist was ich als Königsklasse
der Comedy bezeichnen möchte muss man
als Schauspieler komplett verschwinden
hinter der Figur die man parodiert und
das ist enorm schwierig und das kann
sicherlich auch nicht jeder und ich habe
auch improvisiert in der Schillerstraße
und jetzt mache ich einen Talk Format im
Grunde genommen was ja gar nicht Comedy
ist in für den RBB in der nachttachse
das sind schon sehr verschiedene Sachen
das stimmt schon ähm wo ich aber auch
immer bereit bin zu scheitern ich weiß
ja nicht ob es funktioniert
also das Abenteuer suche ich und nehme
die Herausforderung immer an und ähm
gucke dann wie es ausgeht das heißt
diese Bereitschaft so scheitern ist
vielleicht eine Voraussetzung dafür ja
wir haben bei der Schillerstraße nicht
gewusst ob das funktioniert wir haben
uns alle in die Hosen gemacht am Anfang
und waren uns nicht sicher und plötzlich
wieder sein riesen Erfolg das weiß man
eben vorher nicht aber man muss erstmal
ja dazu sagen und da leitet mich einfach
meinen Instinkt und mein Kopf und aber
auch mein Bauch zu den Dingen wo ich ja
sage und wo ich aber auch dann nein sage
ja da gibt's einige da gibt's einige
Sachen ja okay gut
aber gerne
du musst immer wissen wenn du aufhörst
zu ziehen wirst du nicht erfahren ja wir
müssen ja alle ziehen jetzt oh schon
wieder eine rote
haben sie die Schauspielschule besucht
weil sie kein Naturtalent haben haha
nein ich Schauspielerei ist ein Handwerk
und deswegen wie ich vorhin auch schon
mal sagte bin ich der festen Überzeugung
dass man sein Handwerk lernen sollte und
die Ausbildung bereichert einen einfach
und es war eine der besten Zeiten meines
Lebens das war einfach super toll und
man lernt ja nicht nur spielen man lernt
singen und Fechten und kämpfen und was
weiß ich nicht alles also das ist schon
ratsam auch wenn man Talent haben muss
um überhaupt darauf also wenn man kein
Talent hat nutzt wahrscheinlich diese
Ausbildung auch nicht viel wenn man kein
Talent hat kommt man auch glaube ich
nicht wirklich auf eine gute
Schauspielschule gewagt aber ja ich
stelle diese These mal jetzt so gewagt
in den Raum okay
sie schreiben verfilmt Fernsehen Bühne
und sogar Bücher wie kann man sich einen
so differenzierten Schreibstil aneignen
gute Frage ich war gewohnt dialogisch zu
schreiben in für Theaterstücke oder für
Fernseh Sketche oder oder Konzepte die
ich entwickelt habe betrieblicher
geschrieben habe das Buch für die
nachttaxe war ja mein erstes Buch da
musste ich mich schon sehr umstellen es
war wieder eine Herausforderung die ich
wieder probiert habe einfach wo ich mich
dann dran setze und sie oft sehr
autodidaktisch dran gehe und ich bin
dann so ehrgeizig ich möchte das
schaffen und ich versuche das dann aber
das war schon ja das war ganz anders zu
schreiben und war ganz ungewohnt für
mich und
beantwortet für meinen Geschmack sehr
sehr schön für meinen auch das ist ja
süß aber gerne immer mehr rote das ist
ja
ihr habt mehr rote rein getan als grüne
nur eine Rote Meer
ist lässt sich jetzt nicht mehr
überprüfen
rot ist ja eher Ruhe rosa oder ich habe
so eine Farbschwäche
sie passivieren Günther Jauch Peter
Klöppel und Florian Silbereisen wollen
sie auch den Erfolg dieser Person
nachahmen weil sie selbst nicht so
berühmt sind hat ihr ein Feuerzeug oder
so dass ich das Anzünden kann nein
sicherlich nicht nein nein nein nein der
Erfolg dieser drei Menschen ist ja auch
sehr unterschiedlich ich meine sind
alles sehr erfolgreiche Leute Günther
Jauch ist mega erfolgreich Peter Klöppel
und Florian Silbereisen aber nein nein
ich mache die einfach ein riesen Spaß
die drei Herren zu parodieren aber an
ihren Erfolg den will ich nicht nach
haben wie ist das wenn man in deren Haut
steckt unterschiedlich
was ist die schönste und also sie machen
alles Spaß ja sie machen alles Spaß aber
es gibt doch schon Unterschiede ne sage
ich mal so in im Outfit allein in der
Kleidung in der Frisur da gibt es
schillere Persönlichkeiten und etwas
normalerweise trockenere persönlich in
welchem willst du denn naja Klöppel ist
natürlich wahnsinnig die Frisur die
Anzüge das ist ja unglaublich ja da
flippt man ja aus wenn man das sieht und
Silbereisen ist ja eher so ruhig
gediegen ein trockenes Brötchen
wer weiß
grün ist die Hoffnung
und ihr fragt mich
sogar die Person die Sie per
persiflieren sind begeistert von ihrer
Darstellung wie schaffen Sie das naja
vor der Kamera sagen sie dass sie das
lustig finden
was die wirklich denken das wissen wir
ja nicht das sagen wir uns ja auch nicht
denn mit steigendem Erfolg von Switch
Reloaded sind viele
Opfer erstaunlich gut gelaunt und finden
das erstaunlich lustig und witzig und
das glaube ich ihnen nicht immer wobei
Katharina Salz Frank die hat sich
beschwert die super nenne die ist sauer
Katharina sich sich schlecht parodiert
und fand die Nummern unlustig aber gut
manche Menschen geben ihm zum Lachen
nicht
rote als Rest jetzt die grüne gezogen
und hier steht sie streamen live ins
Internet und twittern während der Fahrt
mit dem Berliner nachttaxi machen sie
Comedy 2.0 Berliner nachttaxi ist nicht
wirklich Comedy aber ich würde sagen
Casas Knigge die ist Comedy 2.0 weil
oder kann ich jetzt Knigge die gesagt ja
Comedy sag mal ähm kennst das Knigge ist
Comedy 2.0 weil ähm das kommt der ich
glaube Internet Sehgewohnheit auch vor
allem der jungen Menschen sehr entgegen
alles sehr sehr schnell clipweise
kompakt und kurz zu sehen und ähm von
daher ist das schon mal 20 und die
nachttaxis mit dem Livestream ein Tag
Format vielleicht 2.0 finde ich schon ja
absolut gut nur noch drei rote es ist ja
eigentlich egal jetzt wird's schlimm
jetzt wird's ganz grässlich dreimal rot
ein Mann sieht rot
mussten sie für kesslers Knigge erst
lernen sich zu benehmen um zu wissen wie
man sich nicht mitnehmen sollte
nein ich bin ein wohlerzogener junge
meine Eltern haben schon ganz früh
darauf geachtet dass die Ellenbogen
nicht auf den Tisch kommen und dass ich
Gabel und Messer richtig halte und nicht
schmatze von daher
nein benehme ich mich eigentlich relativ
anständig wie lange ist dir diese Idee
durch den Kopf gegangen welche kesslers
Knigge also überhaupt diese es gibt eine
es gab eine Vorlage dafür irgendwo im
Internet so in der Richtung und dann
haben wir aber schon lange überlegt ob
sich das in eine Sendung von 25 Minuten
bauen lässt statt einer Minute Clip da
wir schon mehrere Monate überlegt und
geschrieben und brainstormt
gut noch zwei rote ich mache hier eine
riesensäure
ganz schnell nachher
zusammen
die hat wahrscheinlich besonders
ist die Produktion
des Quiz Taxis nicht sehr aufwendig
irgendwo ein Fehler drin ich glaube sehr
aufwendig ist falsch geschrieben nee die
dpa schreibt auch wenn ich jetzt wieder
so mit E das nicht der Fehler das ist ja
der Fluch der Berliner nachttaxe wenn
ich durch Berlin fahre dann werde ich
oft gerne mal so in den Stadtteilen
Kreuzberg und Neukölln von
tiefergelegten BMWs verfolgt die glauben
ich sei das Christ Taxi liebe Zuschauer
die Sendung des Quiz Taxi ist glaube ich
jetzt schon seit anderthalb Jahren
abgesetzt und wird nicht mehr produziert
sie sehen nur noch Wiederholungen auf
kabel eins was sie aber immer noch sehen
können ist die Berliner nachttag sind
und die hat mit dem Quiz Taxi nichts zu
tun es gibt auch kein Geld zu gewinnen
und nichts die sind immer ganz
enttäuscht wenn Sie das Hören ja ja die
denken
ich will ein Stein ich will gewinnen
das ist nicht das Gesicht
und die Kamera
nun gut
letzte Frage die letzte Frage
ausgeschüttelt erzählt sie etwas über
ihr Privatleben schön dass die dann auch
zum Schluss kommt ich erzähle nie was
über meinen Privatleben komisch nee weil
mein Privatleben ist ja privat deswegen
das ich sage immer das können gerne
andere Kollegen tun die können sich da
in irgendwelchen Gazetten austoben und
ihre scheidungsgeschichten erzählen und
ihre Wohnungen zeigen und ihre Häuser
und Paläste und welches Auto Sie fahren
das brauche ich alles nicht ähm
das ist der letzte Rückzug eines
Menschen der im öffentlichen Leben steht
und das muss ich nicht auch noch
öffentlich machen das heißt von Dir wird
es nie den Satz zu hören geben ja wir
sind ein paar nein das wird sie geben
und ich mache ich koche auch nicht in
meiner Wohnung und ich Gärtner nicht in
meinem Garten und mit Kameras das tue
ich alles nicht
hat gab es da mal eine Entscheidung wo
gesagt hast die gibt es schon immer die
war schon von vornherein klar oder hast
du irgendwann mal eine schlechte
Erfahrung gemacht oder gesehen bei
Kollegen nein ich habe das von Anfang an
war mir klar dass ich in diesem Beruf
gerne durch meinen können vielleicht
auffalle oder den Menschen gefallen aber
nicht dadurch welche Socken ich trage
oder dass ich irgendjemanden von dem ich
scheiden lasse oder
keine Ahnung was sich die Menschen da
alles ausdenken um Aufmerksamkeit zu
bekommen ich versuche die Aufmerksamkeit
anders zu bekommen und wenn es mal
schlechte Zeiten gibt kitzelt dann ich
habe kein Management man macht doch mal
eine home Story Gott sei Dank nicht äh
ich verstehe mich mit meinem Management
so gut dass wir uns da völlig einig sind
bevor ich in einen Dschungel gehe ich
lieber kennen
okay dann in diesem Sinne vielen Dank
danke ich habe mich auch gefreut danke
danke schön